[Music]
a subway worker
uh like like foot long subways ah five
dollars
yeah i had to clarify yo is this still
five dollars no hell no bruh
it's like they're venti or some [ __ ]
they're fantastic
they got it they got a new one i forgot
i was at a subway recently
let me explore their menu comes in a cup
they said we're giving away a million
subs classic stunts
got the foot long and then they got this
new one that i saw and i'm like damn
that's a big ass trace lay chase
just three sandwiches on top of each
other all cheese
shopping wet milk between
you ever had a milk sandwich
like a party one sandwich yeah when you
go to a party and someone had a big
[ __ ] subway you're just like wow
they're like
that's a crazy like these people are
bald or
we had this one kid in my sixth grade
class
he would like during lunch he would go
to the fence and his mom would pass this
up with you and i thought he was the
most bothered [ __ ] kid or yummy kid
ever because everyone's eating cafeteria
food and this was getting the [ __ ]
subway through the fence yeah that's
when the subway was hot bro
crazy that's what it was for the weight
loss it was the heyday
went to subway to hang out yeah yeah
yeah the cookies are firing right in bro
he looked back she probably just forgot
to pack his lunch and she [ __ ] had to
buy him some way
we're eating [ __ ] taco bells and [ __ ]
tacos we're good man it does sound good
you guys remember when subway had like
newspaper walls
yes
yeah it was like and it was like pretty
old-timey deli it was all tummy daily i
was more of a quiz notice guys i'm not
gonna lie
i knew a couple of those kids didn't
know i was gonna offend this fool's core
um so a subway worker was actually shot
dead whoa in front of her son oh after
an argument with a customer about too
much mayo on his sandwich why is her son
at her work i have no idea probably to
take away to witness the death
oh wow that's dark police uh police said
officers responded to the shooting uh in
atlanta uh at a gas station actually
there's a subway gas station one of
those um it's another anthony article oh
you didn't even preface this that this
one's gonna be sad we're making [ __ ]
fun sandwich jokes so now it's like not
funny
yeah dude
subway subway's [ __ ] sad dude i was
in front of riverside
see that's the preface i said subway
nowadays riverside and i was like okay
cool i was getting like my wheels put on
i'm just getting a [ __ ] lunch so i go
in there and there's this crazy homeless
like this taking a shower at the soda
fountain oh no and then uh i was looking
at i was like okay i'm gonna look at the
workers maybe they i don't know they
have eyes on this and it was like these
two ladies that were scared for their
life and i'm like oh [ __ ] so what did
you do
as the man in the subway did you run
away too no i went to go order my
sandwich you ordered the whole sandwich
and you just let this dude i don't know
what that is [ __ ] having a soda bag
get a drink and you're like oh excuse me
no i ordered a bottle of drinks i have
to deal with his ass
true luxury right there you gotta get a
cookie the cat a wish the subway cookies
city boy dude have you tried um have you
tried firehouse subs it's good it's good
yeah
it's like a fireman theme it's like a
fire department they donate all this
[ __ ] to the bunch of firemen is that in
vegas only no it's like in california
too it's a chain yeah yeah but they're
usually like in the desert i feel like
there's a desert prerequisite for a
firehouse sub i've never seen it outside
yeah i've actually been uh boycotting
subway for the last like probably like
20 years it's pretty gross dude
on purpose because
yeah like literally any single time
somebody is like hey let's get like
subway or something like who [ __ ]
asks for wait i love that you're so
[ __ ] done before you've actually said
yo let's get some sometimes sometimes
like a production shoot or something
like that you'd be like subways for
lunch or whatever well no that makes
sense because it's cheap but i would
still not eat a boycott all the time
because i [ __ ] hate it i had a little
twinkle in my eye when i talked about
subway number one
one time one time i got food poisoning
from a subway right so that just makes
you feel type one what was the order but
i don't know what's up meatball i love
it
but it was actually
uh another time i went into a subway and
this is with an ex-girlfriend at the
time
during college and i go in there and
it's just like this white chick who's
working and she's like she looks a
little bit younger than me i was in
college at the time she looked a little
bit younger right and then uh she was
kind of personable it's one of those hey
welcome subway type stuff i don't
remember what i might have been an
[ __ ] a little bit about it but i i
think i cracked some sort of like light
joke definitely it wasn't anything to
merit some weird ass psychotic behavior
and then she looks at me um what does
she say
she does i don't even think she says
anything she just changes her attitude
looks at me like this is something not a
comedy
[Applause]
you want tuna you want the [ __ ]
meatball what do you want
it might have been the case but she was
[ __ ] she looks at me pissed off she
stares at me like she's going to
literally hurt my family she stares at
me in a [ __ ] very very malicious way
uh while she's trying to fix my sandwich
the energy is really weird
and then after that i was like dude i'm
never gonna [ __ ] order subway again
if she were though that's not on subway
i know but still i think it was i think
it was you dude
i want to know what the joke was
subway corporate came down and was like
and when anthony lee walks in the door
[ __ ] that guy
you
to anthony he's like yo who's got the
sticky [ __ ] huh
hey once you close your legs there
sweetheart whoa whoa whoa i didn't order
the tuna fish yet
i don't know why she's so bad
why is she so [ __ ] mad [ __ ] women
right
walks it drops a sticky [ __ ] jumping
[ __ ] up boy anthony walks in and the
bell rings from the door and he's like
he's like whoa i thought that was
a bell was around your [ __ ] neck
your cow
[ __ ] cow
just anthony from the 1940s
you guys know anthony that's what he's
really like i don't know what i said
what's the [ __ ] big idea it's just a
[ __ ] joke it goes into rodney
dangerfield
oh man non-stop ball crapper the whole
time
because they're bad they're really bad
for it maybe we can start a gofundme for
that branch of subway that you [ __ ]
yeah
level it bring it to the ground you know
what you know what i'm like still
curious of how come you have friends
who say
who volunteer and say i want subway like
no jimmy johns no [ __ ] no no you know
i mean at least the quiznos yeah jersey
mice i mean come on man or a local
italian place like this nice little deli
right here or even a rouse you know they
got a good sandwich which is pretty good
actually you know you go to the park
they got a nice little deli over the
sushi section
authentic there's definitely an asian
person making it always is
always is
authentic i've never heard of this it's
just i don't know it just it breaks my
heart man who volunteers
subway as an option dude that's
disgusting unless you got to take a bath
then it's a good place to go unless
you're on riverside you have to
if you're in riverside dude yeah
devastating every time i drive by a
subway nobody is ever in there not even
workers like because people taking
showers i feel like even the people that
work there the workers don't come out
until you walk in yeah and then they're
like they come out of the back get off
their little box and they're like all
right uh what do you want they put their
gloves on and shoot subway gremlins
why can't they sit on chairs even they
don't they can't afford them yeah subway
don't give it to me what did jared do
again he molested kids
michael i thought he had child porn he
probably touched kids he was michael
jackson all over the world oh say
michael jackson he was michael jackson
yeah yeah he was for sure he was he
definitely wants somebody wonderland
neverland
jared did have a really good music voice
though he was a very musical man was he
was he a part of a musical very much so
very much so there's a common thing
yeah yeah
there's a comment
you haven't you haven't heard jared
soundcloud it's really good are you
[ __ ] with me right now did you guys
watch the documentary where he was like
hanging out with kids and he was like
having sleep builders and [ __ ]
at the subway
subway playground yeah yeah dude all
right as much as you guys hate subway
what is your favorite go-to there i
gotta get the meatball every time am i
on a diet or not on a diet oh just like
for food for fun oh the meatball then
really with cheese cause it's like a
pizza in a second i haven't had that in
ages that was my kid go to one the
meatball black forest ham
well that's a good one for fun
i'm not at subway for fun
that's not the problem with the meatball
marinara is it's like [ __ ] messy
right then in there yet i don't remember
the last time i had soda do you guys
want to get that for lunch today
sounds delicious i want the soup too
they probably just get the meat and they
just [ __ ] squeeze the [ __ ] juice
out and put a microwave yeah that sounds
delicious
you guys don't like the cold cut trio
that's just cool
i lived on cold country in the college
like but the cold country you gotta get
it toasted and then you add it on you
know everything about it is joking
like two decades yeah probably two
decades that's how your boy your
boycott's been going on that strong
there's so many other options though
like jimmy john's firehouse
is better yeah together
dude anything is better than someone
this is like the meme though where the
like you're in the elevator with jon
hamm and then subway is like hey anthony
lee i don't even think about you at all
doing fine i think without your business
mother elevator with john hamm talking
about subway's future
mad men he's just like i don't think
about you at all i only know it from
meme form it's
never never even seen that scene before
[Music]
[Music]